bonsoir ultimatum chez renault à la
veille du salon de l'ouverture du salon
de l'automobile et du lancement d'un
nouveau modèle semaine d'action à aider
fo ptt
dans les transports les arsenaux la cgt
proclame depuis quelques jours qu'elle
va frapper fort
si je vous ai demandé de venir ce soir
monsieur krasucki c'est parce que les
français s'interrogent
ça signifie quoi frapper fort et qui
voulez vous frapper alors chez renault
par exemple qui visez vous est ce la
direction de la régie dont vous
critiquer ouvertement la stratégie
industrielle alors qu'elle traverse tout
le monde le sait une passe difficile
ou bien visez-vous l'état patron c'est à
dire en fait le gouvernement qui fixe
les grands axes de la politique de
renault notamment en matière de
modernisation
monsieur krasucki vous êtes communiste
depuis l'âge de 14 ans très jeune vous
vous êtes engagé dans la résistance est
à cause de cela vous avez été déporté en
la paix revenue vous avez gravi tous les
échelons de la cgt et du parti
communiste vous êtes aujourd'hui
secrétaire général de la première est
membre du bureau politique du second
alors ce soir nos questions et je suis
sûr que vous vous y attendez ne
s'adresseront pas seulement au
secrétaire général de cgt mais aussi
bien sûr hauts dignitaires du parti
alors vous connaissez la règle de notre
émission questions sans complaisance et
réponses franches et si possible courte
alors avant de vous laisser avec les
téléspectateurs qui appelle actuellement
svp avant de vous laisser avec alain
duhamel avec guy claeys directeur de la
rédaction du matin avec albert du roy
directeur adjoint de la rédaction
d'antenne 2 eh bien je voudrais vous
poser une première question à laquelle
vous pouvez répondre très brièvement au
bout d'aller répondre même par un seul
chiffre
combien y at-il aujourd'hui d'adhérents
à la cgt si je vous posais des questions
c'est parce que depuis deux ans depuis
votre congrès de lille vous entretenez
un très soigneusement le secret sur ce
chiffre
je réponds d'avoir à la question et je
commenterai ensuite peut-être par la
question agite actuellement
nous estimons entre un million trois
cent mille et un million quatre cent
mille le nombre d'adhérents actifs et
autour de 300 mille retraités
au moment de notre précédent au moment
de notre précédent congrès il y avait un
million six cent mille actifs gérés de
manière mais pas non non voilà en ce qui
concerne le secret c'est pas un problème
de secret mais la cgt c'est pas une
administration c'est pas comme les
impôts on n'augmente pas si on est en
retard de cotisation c'est une
organisation bénévole alors il faut du
temps tout simplement pour que l'argent
remontée nous faisons nos comptes quand
nous pouvons boucler le bilan réellement
que nous faisons honnêtement vous
pourriez de faire tous les ans nous
faisons à chaque congrès régulièrement
parce que là tout le monde paye ses
cotisations et les fait remonter sinon
il peut pas participer au vote
il nous permet d'avoir le chiffre à peu
près exact de nos choix qu'il faut quand
même rappeler que après la guerre vous
aviez après la scission avec fo 47,48
vous aviez 4 millions d'adhérents
mais si vous pensez que c'est pas si je
suis d'accord avec vous mais nous en
parlerons tous d'accord on attendra tout
à l'heure alors première question svp
jean-louis la scène bonsoir comme vous
pouviez vous attendre
c'est ce qui se passe en ce moment même
à la régie renault qui est au centre des
préoccupations des téléspectateurs qui
appelle ce soir et ce bp la plupart des
fiches condamne votre action et l'action
de la cgt en termes parfois très dure
un exemple parmi d'autres cette
téléspectatrice de paris trouve votre
appel à la grève
révoltant en ces temps de crise où tant
de français demande à ta travailler
alors deux questions pour commencer si
vous le voulez bien
ne vous sentez vous pas gêné de mener à
la catastrophe le secteur automobile
français et autre interrogation pourquoi
les grèves à chaque sortie d'un nouveau
modèle c'est direct oui questions
directes réponse directe d'abord sur
commencera par la deuxième grosse grève
à la sortie de chaque modèle précisément
ici se passe quelque chose de tout à
fait incompréhensible de le connais
depuis longtemps la régie renault
c'est la première fois depuis plusieurs
dizaines d'années que je
voilà une chose pareille en général
quand on sort un nouveau modèle pour
stimuler des travailleurs pour leur
donner du coeur à l'ouvragé
on fait quelque chose est bien là on
commence par leur annoncer qu'il va y
avoir beaucoup de suppressions d'emplois
ensuite on leur dit que ils ont touché 2
% en tout depuis le 1er janvier sur les
salaires et puis on va alors réduire
leur treizième mois
et puis enfin on va les ennuyer dans la
manière de prendre leur cinquième
semaine de congés payés
si c'est comme ça qu'on mobilise des
gens pour travailler je n'ai jamais vu
cela allait revêtir la direction de la
régie sabote finalement le lancement de
ce nouveau problème
elle a fait quelque chose
d'incompréhensible ne pouvait pas
s'étonner d'obtenir ce résultat
à moins qu'ils aient pensé qu'elle
allait trouver des travailleurs a battu
là c'est une autre question
s'ils pensaient trouver des des moutons
et ben ils ont trouvé des lions parce
que derrière le motif immédiate
il y a quelque chose de plus fondamental
d'une part le pouvoir d'achat de ces
travailleurs mais plus encore l'avenir
justement de l'entreprise et l'avenir de
l'emploi pour tous ouvriers employés
techniciens agents de maîtrise et cas
puisqu'on annonce de nombreuses
suppressions d'emplois aussi bien chez
les cols blancs que chez les cols bleus
c'est ce qui a été annoncé
et bien c'est cela qui est l'arrière
plan de ce qui se passe actuellement
chirurgie très bien mais on va y revenir
il y avait une deuxième partie la
question le sen fou et nous le rappeler
ne vous sentez vous pas gêné de mener à
la catastrophe
le secteur automobile français mais j'ai
au contraire le sentiment non pas moi
parce que ce sont les travailleurs avec
la cgt et aussi avec les autres
syndicats jours observé mais ce sont les
travailleurs qui par leurs actions
agissent utilement pour la sauvegarde de
l'industrie automobile française qui est
bien malade
du fait de la manière dont elle y
conduit bon eh bien vous allez expliquer
tout ça leur alain duhamel va venir
s'asseoir pour un premier quart d'heure
ensuite nous retournerons à -cp alors
alain duhamel
non une première question que je crois
on se pose beaucoup qui est cette grève
ces grèves parce qu'on a dans plusieurs
usines est-ce qu'elles viennent
spontanément de la base parce qu'il ya
un mécontentement particulier en ce
moment où des appréhensions
particulières ou bien ce que c'est la
cgt qui a décidé de laisser ils ont de
l'estimé lieu de les déclencher
maintenant il ya eu beaucoup de
déclarations ces temps ci des principaux
responsables de la cgt soit au niveau
confédéral soit dans la branche soit
dans l'entreprise qui appelait à des
mouvements alors ça vient de vous vous
ça vient des salariés ou des deux ça
vient des deux vous avez raison alors
pourquoi parce que pourquoi c'est la
rencontre entre un état d'esprit des
travailleurs et des initiatives d'une
organisation syndicale
d'ailleurs suivi d'autres organisations
syndicales parce que elle se fait la cgt
en l'occurrence le porte parole de ce
qu'il ya dans la tête des gens concernés
mais pourquoi meilleure preuve de la
meilleure preuve c'est ce qui est arrivé
au mans vous vous rendez compte à peine
annoncé des mesures dont je viens de
parler
et voilà une usine complètement occupé
par toutes les catégories de personnel
tout le monde y était les ouvriers la
maîtrise et c'est une entreprise où il
n'ya pas d'immigrés d'ailleurs toutes
les entreprises actuellement de chez
renault qui sont en lutte sont des
entreprises essentiellement composée de
travailleurs français voulait très
différent de ce qui s'était passé chez
citroën ou je le signale en passant
moi je vous ai pas interrogé là-dessus
non mais je je c'est une petite
parenthèse mais l'ancien chauffeur il ya
des parenthèse utile y en a peut-être
d'inutiles celle là je crois qu'il est
utile donc en l'espace d'une journée
lusine s'est trouvée immobilisée tout le
monde arrêter quand des choses pareilles
arrive moi j'étais à toulouse en voyage
syndicale
quand j'ai su cela je n'ai même pas pris
la peine de téléphoner pour savoir ce
qui se passe j'ai compris que ces
choses-là n'arrivent que quand c'est
fort dans l'esprit des gens personne ne
peut sur un ordre faire arrêter une
usine ainsi et quand ça commence à
provoquer des répercussions dans les
autres usines du groupe
ça veut dire qui se passe réellement
quelque chose de profond mais pourquoi
maintenant c'est ça la question d'alain
duhamel pourquoi m'as tu peux très bien
j'ai laissé non c'est moi qui pour
épurer et je sais que vous n'avez pas
répondu
alors qui revient j'y reviens pourquoi
maintenant la cgt voit là écoutez
comment vous dire vous imaginez que
c'est moi qui suis allé subrepticement
au petit matin trouver monsieur ah non
le surprendre alors si la moitié
monsieur annoncé le patron de red bull
de chez renault alors qu'il est pas tout
à fait réveillez vous voyez au petit
jour qui lui glisser dans l'oreille un
bon tuyau qui savent et sucrés l'heure
le 13e mois
et puis embêter les pour les congés
payés et vous allez faire un tabac et
puis que lui bêtement il m'aura écoutez
vous pensez que c'est ça qui est arrivé
c'est lui qui a choisi ça lui et puis
ceux qui l'ont conseillé aux laurentides
a prévenu jean dreuil cette décision ils
ont entraîné cette réaction évidemment
donc c'est la direction de renault
d'après-vous sa direction de renault qui
en fait est responsable directement de
l'ensemble des mouvements
l'intéressement
elle a d'abord créé des conditions de
l'éclatement de ce conflit précis mais
ce conflit précis je le dis parce que je
le pensais elle vous dit je connais
renault depuis longtemps et je crois
avoir une certaine idée de la situation
générale du pays
c'est un signe ce conflit précis n'a pu
avoir cette dimension que parce que
c'est en fait la goutte d'eau
qui fait déborder le vase il ya une
accumulation de mécontentement
d'inquiétude et même de colère est bon
des dispositions comme celles qui ont
été annoncées ont provoqué ces réactions
la à cette rentrée là spécialement
maintenant là parce que en même temps
s'annonce
je ne sais combien de suppressions
d'emplois sans discussion et que les
gens n'ont toujours touché depuis le 1er
janvier que 2 % d'augmentation et vivent
avec ça depuis le 1er janvier ce qu'est
ce qui a bien fait des négociations qui
était prévu qu'ils sont toujours prévue
du prix demain d'ailleurs avec la
direction
et ça fait plusieurs jours ça fait même
un peu près deux semaines que les
principaux responsables de la cgt
concernées multiplient des appels et
bien oui ça c'est fini parce que d'abord
ce qui est arrivé donne une idée de
d'une manière de traiter les gens au
bout d'un moment les gens se sentent un
peu floués et ils ont y perdre confiance
chez renault il aurait fallu faire
depuis trois ans déjà une grande
politique sociale
je lui ai proposé à l'époque au premier
ministre alors monsieur mauroy c'est pas
ce qui s'est produit est maintenant il
n'y croit par ailleurs et vous voyez à
quel point ils ont raison de ne pas y
croire et le syndicat cgt la fédération
de la métallurgie avec eux c'est que il
a fallu que flins soient occupés
complètement pour que l' affaire se
règle par une négociation vite fait
qu'on attendait non je réponds à votre
question
les autres aussi longtemps qu'ils n'ont
pas fait la même chose exactement que
flins on dit j'entendais tout à l'heure
les informations se diversement suivis
chez popote cominar est pas tout comme
ils n'occupent pas complètement alors
que il cherche une solution
on leur dit ce que vous faites ça sert à
rien on les pousse à décider les
méthodes les plus énergiques si c'est ça
qu'on veut on va y arriver alors deux
jours nous voulons que de choisir que
les négociations s'ouvrent pour aboutir
première fois négocié faut aboutir
premièrement dans les formes d'action
jusqu'où êtes vous prêt à aller jusqu'où
les travailleurs estiment ans
c'est nécessaire et jusqu'où il faudra
que ça c'est pas une réponse c'est vague
ah ben ça à quels critères vous jugerez
que votre action est réussie non
résultats bien suivre c'est quoi le
résultat
le résultat c'est les solutions aux
problèmes posés alors non mais alors non
ce n'est pas la réponse à ma question ça
je vous demander jusqu'où vous êtes
prêts à aller où s'ouvre de ta inciter
les salariés à aller
est-ce que vous êtes prêts à les inciter
à aller jusque aux occupations d'usinés
compris dans la région parisienne ou pas
ça c'est quand même vous avez point de
vue j'ai un point de vue alors
mais quand vous me dites ce n'est pas
une réponse que je vous ai dit tout à
l'heure permettez moi de vous dire
monsieur duhamel que vous vous
connaissez mal où je crois vous faites
comme si vous connaissiez mal les
travailleurs l'action syndicale des
travailleurs ne sont pas une armée la
cgt n'est pas une armée et je ne suis
pas un général et prend vie n'est nous
sommes une organisation de volonté et de
travailleurs pacifique d'ailleurs qui
ont des intérêts à défendre ses
syndicats bon alors ça ne se décrète pas
comme ça quand vous me devons vous dit
vous n'êtes pas satisfait parce que je
ne vous ai pas dit je suis prêt jusqu'à
faire ceci j'utilise faire cela c'est
pas c'est pas ainsi que ça se passe mais
je ne vous dis pas ça je suis prêt à ce
qu'est ce que je vais vous dire
maintenant bon d'après de mon avis oui
parce que qui est aussi celui de tous
mes camarades de la direction de la
civilité
allez-y aussi loin que les travailleurs
voudront pour une raison qu'il faut
retenir
parce que personne ne peut obliger les
travailleurs à faire quoi que ce soit
pas plus nou que qui compte s'ils ne
veulent pas faire la grève la cgt pourra
toujours dire une faut faire la grève il
ne la feront pas deuxièmement par contre
ça s'est déjà vu c'est pas facile de les
arrêter
une fois qu'ils sont partis donc pas si
simple mais jeudi avec eux au fur et à
mesure du déroulement des événements et
bien plus
il faudra y mettre de force et de
dynamisme
plus vous le mettrez nous vous
conseillons de le faire et vous jugerez
nous juge
ensemble vous travailleurs et nous
syndicats ce la même chose de la valeur
des résultats
alors si ça doit être une occupation ça
sera une occupation ce sera d'abord la
faute à la direction puisque il lui
suffit pas ici on ne fait pas comme
moment ils sont pas qu'ils n'y croient
pas et ben si ça doit être une
occupation ça sera ça mais ce qui est
vrai pour renault est vrai au delà si si
il faut pour se faire entendre
faire la grève nous disons aux
travailleurs à notre avis plutôt que
d'en prendre plein la figure
eh bien il faut faire la grève si il
faut occuper
nous préférerions ne pas avoir à le
faire mais si vous en êtes d'accord vous
les travailleurs et si vous pensez que
sinon ça va aller mal pour vous et que
c'est inacceptable et bien occupons s'il
faut des manifestations et des
manifestations massives dans les
localités et au plan national
eh bien faisons l'est après tout
d'autres l'ont fait et ils ont été
écoutés
alors la régie renault ne va pas bien
elle va perdre beaucoup d'argent cette
année c'est un moment important pour
elle puisque il ya à la fois le salon de
l'automobile tca qui compte beaucoup et
puis pascal lancement de ce nouveau
modèle
la super 5 est ce que vous ne craignez
pas avec les méthodes d'action qui sont
choisis en ce moment à ce moment-là
précis ce que vous ne craignez pas de
désavantager la régie renault à la fois
par rapport à ses rivaux français du
secteur privé jour et en même temps par
rapport aux autres grandes marques
européennes
est ce que au fond d'une certaine
manière est-ce que ça n'est pas un peu
la politique du pire
non c'est en l'occurrence ce serait la
direction qui prendrait les travailleurs
en otage à cause du lancement d'un
nouveau modèle
on lance un nouveau modèle écrasé vous
c'est ça que vous proposez la notion
jamais j'essaie de comprendre
je ne négocie pas avec nous je vous pose
de questions mais d'accord
mais j'essaie de comprendre le sens de
ma condition qu'on ait bien voilà vous
voyez alors donc si les travailleurs
s'est jamais le bon moment pour se
défendre
qu'ils sont sûrs d'être laminés parlons
des problèmes de la régie renault parce
qu'il y en a effectivement à chaque fois
qu'il y en a un qu'est ce qu'on dit
qu'il ya trop de monde sur effectif
c'est l'histoire du poumon dans le
malade imaginaire le poumon le poumon le
bon ben alors les voitures sont trop
chers la 3d effectif il y adhérer de
trop de retouche
il ya des défauts dans ces voitures il
ya trop effectif il ya des trop longs
délais de livraison il ya trop
d'effectif on met en forme les
entreprises font chômage partiel ou
grands hits c'est pas sérieux un pâtre à
l'affectif d'après vous attendez
examinons les problèmes après on va
parler des effectifs aussi je vous
assure et parce que c'est ma question
ah ben on va y venir mais avant je tiens
donc prenons les choses pour ce qu'elles
sont 1
si renault comme les autres
constructeurs français se vendent moins
sur le marché français il ya des raisons
elle a plusieurs pour ce qui est du prix
vous dire quelque chose qui va peut-être
surprendre mais
renault puisqu'on parle d'elle vend
quasiment à perte à l'étranger parce
qu'on dit tout à l'exportation et se
rattrape sur le consommateur français
c'est pour ça que les voitures
comparables renault coûtent plus chers
que leurs concurrents étrangers mariés
que les autres font un peu la même chose
c'est ce que je vais vous tuer oui mais
ça signifie un désordre dans les
échanges internationaux complètement fou
parce que ça conduit à des catastrophes
vous êtes d'accord c'est pas du tout
propre à la région jeudi toutes les
grandes marques mais je dis ça conduit à
des catastrophes d'accord vous en
convenez vous êtes un genre konami je
crois alors je reconnais que la régie
renault fait comme les autres voilà bon
mais que mais que ça c'est une situation
anormale
parce qu'on peut pas en vivre de cette
manière là ce rpi aux consommateurs que
de son pays
ce qu'ont les cadeaux qu'on fait aux
yeux c'est pareil pour le délai de
livraison ou est ce qu'on peut leur est
donnée pour une seule marque à la fois
autrement dit compter quelque chose
comme ça c'est à dire qu'elles démarrent
qui font toutes les marques qui font
effectivement payé plus cher sur le
marché intérieur
moins cher sur le marché étranger en
france
est-ce qu'on peut régler ça simplement
pour renault sans que ce soit un
handicap par rapport aux autres on en
revient toujours à ça e
dans une certaine mesure oui et puis
dans la mesure complémentaire
il ya des problèmes européens il faut il
faut se battre et pourquoi la france ne
lèverait pas le drapeau je dis bien la
france tire la régie renault
l'automobile française et le
gouvernement français est soutenu par
tous ceux qui doivent soutenir le livre
est il pas le drapeau de la propreté
dans les échanges internationaux en
europe et ce plan mondial
parce que pour normal ces choses là
c'est valable pour d'autres un jeu dont
revient en essor que vous agiter le
drapeau de l'automobile française robin
oui revenons un autre un autre sujet
puisque vous chercher des solutions je
peux vous en signaler explications en
même temps des délais des éléments de
solution
alors regardez une firme comme volvo en
suède nous situerons les suédois un
exemple elle a établi un système une
réduction par accord avec les milieux
concernés une réduction de
1 % sur l'essence pour les voitures
volvo en suède
figurez vous que les administrateurs cgt
de la régie renault ceux qui sont élus
par le personnel ils viennent de faire
une proposition du mémorialiste et
chiche pourquoi enfin pas la même chose
on a par exemple vous soyez vous
voudriez qu'on donne une réduction sur
le prix de l'essence aux français qui
roulerait en renault mais pourquoi pas
puisque les suédois le font bien ça leur
réussit c'est ça une idée parmi d'autres
non c'est pas bête quand même non gbagbo
fera ce qu on pourrait bien un peu
avantagé le consommateur français
pourquoi puisqu'on le lez par ailleurs
mais je mentirais cet exemple le droit
de faire ça abel messieurs doit le font
bien positionné se fera sans pas dans le
marché commun les suédois bon mais vous
savez ce que les autres font tout le
monde triche dans le marché que minfopra
glodé d'histoire c'est la france qui
triche le moins mais ça on pourra en
parler
bon on pourra en parler à propos en
général des échanges internationaux
c'est pas normal on est plus mal placé
que les autres y aura tout un tas de
créneaux tout simplement parce que les
autres respectent mois la règle du jeu
que nous ouvrait alors que je lisais
dans le monde
juste avant de venir ici d'une nouvelle
qui venaient des états unis et qui
concerne l automobile il y avait des
négociations entre les salariés de la
general motors donc d'une grande firme
automobile du monde
et puis les propriétaires et comme il se
trouve que le prix de revient aux états
unis est plus élevé qu'il ne l'est au
japon les salariés de la general motors
acceptent des augmentations de salaires
inférieures à l'inflation donc avec une
baisse du niveau de vie parce qu'il
pense qu'au fond c'est désagréable sur
le moment mais que c'est leur avantage à
terme parce que ça renforce la firme
dans laquelle ils travaillent
et pourtant à general motors a fait des
gros bénéfices et pas du tout le cas de
renault me regarder votre question là
bas est ce que si vous êtes du genre de
démarche non c'est simple nous pourrions
organiser un référendum parmi les
travailleurs de toutes les orris de
l'automobile français moi je vous pose
deux questions très bonne question
c'est une réponse vienne bang vue on
peut répondre aussi de cette manière là
vous vous dites la réponse c'est pas la
même heure france qu'il faut demander
aux gens vous
vous les voyez accepter ça vous passer
ces images permet pas posé la question
posée la question à d'autres
organisations syndicales que la première
qui se sent et la misère qui se sent
capable d'obtenir ou de proposer une
chose pareille chez nous et vlam je pose
ma question je pose la question
autrement je pose ma question autrement
bon ya pas la régie renault sur un
marché via la régie renault en
concurrence avec d'autres grandes
marques françaises et étrangères
bon la régie renault elle est en
difficulté bon alors on peut imaginer je
veux dire je dis pas que ce soit
souhaitable mais on peut imaginer une
baisse importante du pouvoir d'achat
type de ce que les américains acceptent
bon on peut imaginer ce café fiat en
italie à un moment qui était pendant un
temps de diminuer le nombre d'emplois
pour récupérer ce qu'ils ont fait et
maintenant être en meilleure santé ce
qui se passe pour fiat en italie
est ce que tout ça c'est des méthodes
que vous accepteriez ou pas quel est le
genre au fond quel est le genre d'effort
que vous accepterez de la passe le
travail voilà plutôt que de demander ce
qu'on n'accepte pas demandé - 20 ce que
on accepterait par comparaison tout ça
dans mes réponses comme aucune de ces la
mission de me plaît je vais vous dire
celle qui nous convient nous que nous
proposons parce que des problèmes il y
en a vraiment je vous signale parmi ces
problèmes parce qu'on a pas parlé le
fait mérite d'être mentionnée c'est le
nombre d'oeufs de raie importations de
voitures renault à partir d'entreprises
renault installé à l'étranger
je suis pour je discute pas le fait que
de grandes firmes et besoin d'avoir des
installations acteurs différents points
du monde s'élance et logiciels mais
j'estime que c'est exagéré parce
qu'actuellement il ya vraiment de la
buée ça contribue à aggraver la
situation de la firme alors maintenant
sur les solutions mais ici je je crains
que nous débordons notre temps à tous
les deux c'est le problème
comment aborder la modernisation d'une
entreprise avec les travailleurs en
discutant avec eux et en cherchant les
solutions qui donne de l'efficacité qui
donne le meilleur niveau technique et
qui assure du travail aux gens un
travail utile qui peut être changé qui
n'est pas forcément celui
qu'ils font maintenant mais qui ne soit
pas le chômage or nous concevons notre
réponse et c'est ce que nous demandons
jusqu'à maintenant personne n'a jamais
accepté de nous donner la moindre
information
pour justifier ce qu'on nous dit même
sous un gouvernement de gauche bat
actuellement ça change pas pour ça bon
moment ça ne change pas dont je peux
même vous dire quelque chose que kim au
choc
dans le cas de citroën le gouvernement a
finalement accepté 1906 licenciement
soit disant pour des raisons de
modernisation mais qui au ministère du
travail qui vient ou à matignon on
importe où dans gouvernement qui est
capable de me dire pourquoi 1906 et par
1907 ou 1842 ou ou rien du tout pour
lire aucune aussi passé avec vous ces
sacs rationnement nie pas mais m ils ont
réglé ça sur une base strictement
comptable il ya tant de déficit on
supprime temps de salaire et puis
momentanément
c'est un équilibre mais l'entreprise n'a
pas il n'y a pas de solution technique
et et productive et utile c'est pareil
chez renault pour le moment telles que
les choses s'engage or nous nous
proposons quelque chose de constructif
y'a rien à cacher dans une affaire comme
celle-là vous moderniser une entreprise
elles sont d'ailleurs moderne dont elles
sont peu en retard sur les autres mais
c'est vrai qu'il ya des choses nouvelles
affaires ont décidé de moderniser une
entreprise ça ça se prépare à lavancia
des bureaux d'études des bureaux des
méthodes ils font des projets mais on en
discute pas ni avec les travailleurs ni
avec les les techniciens intéressé ni
avec le syndicat avec personne même dans
une entreprise nationale de la famille
giraud nos ni ailleurs je vous le répète
nous nous demandons si la direction
renault s'engage sur la question de
l'emploi
si la direction renault s'engage à
ouvrir enfin des discussions loyal
cartes sur table sur tous les cas de
modernisation qui sautent qui sont
projetés pour examiner quelles en seront
les conséquences sociales d'emplois et
pour rechercher des solutions qui
permettent d'éviter que les gens
deviennent chômeurs nous sommes d'accord
pour avoir ces 10
pulsion loyal là et si les travailleurs
concernés qui sont pas bêtes et ils sont
souvent trahie qualifier même et si les
organisations syndicales et comité
entreprises peuvent avoir leur mot à
dire
on peut trouver ensemble des solutions
constructives chez renault et me et
renault serait alors l'exemple de ce
qu'il faut faire
en france et pourquoi pas en europe
occidentale bon on retourne à bp merci
alain duhamel
on retourne à -cp d'autres questions
beaucoup de questions sur renault des
questions politiques aussi monsieur
krasucki un fonctionnaire de marseille
vous demande pourquoi avoir attendu le
départ des communistes du gouvernement
pour voir la cgt se réveiller et un
instituteur de versailles
à quoi correspond votre action
puisqu'elle risque de se retourner
contre le gouvernement de gauche
voulez vous vraiment que la droite
revienne au pouvoir que la cgt se
réveille aujourd'hui je ne suis pas sûr
que la personne qui a posé cette
question soient bien informés de ce qui
se passe depuis quelques temps au plan
social au moins dans notre pays parce
que c'est depuis 1980 que la cgt qui a
trouvé à cette époque un certain nombre
de choses intéressantes elle l'a dit
parce que nous savons apprécier ce qui
représente un progrès c'est depuis cette
époque sur certaines questions
il ya des différences et c'est normal
nous sommes un syndicat ne sommes ni un
parti encore moins une institution et
encore moins un gouvernement donc
syndicat yves à son rôle mais au fur et
à mesure quand des problèmes sont
devenus plus aigus nous avons été amenés
à dire un certain nombre de choses et
aussi à dire au travail à attention si
on ne s'en occupe pas ça va pas bien
marché nous avons été opposés au premier
blocage des salaires en 82 nous avons
été opposés au plan de rigueur en 81 38
travailleurs il faut faire quelque chose
nous avons organisé des actions et au
début de l'année au mois de janvier
j'ai eu l'occasion personnellement mais
parlant au nom de la cgt en propres
termes de sonner le tocsin pour dire et
ça presse
il faut y aller il y a péri dans la
demeure et ça a donné
les
les actions des sidérurgistes la marge
du sidérurgiste à paris aussi celle des
chantiers navals aussi celle des dockers
ça fait du monde qui sert aux mais nous
n'avons attendu rien du tout nous avons
agi certes mais vous vous reconnaissez
quand même que l'action chez renault a
un caractère symbolique un mouvement
dans une entreprise nationale qui tient
tout de même ces directives du
gouvernement
vous vous considérez bien que les gens y
accordent plus d'importance d'où la
question de ce spectateur nommé je conte
qui est de dire que finalement il est ce
que cette grève est strictement
revendicatives
ou est ce qu'elle est politique mais
bien compris qui sied bien compris cet
aspect là de la question mais je tenais
d'abord à dire que puisque ça commençait
par là que votre combativité nous étions
et veillez simplement au fur et à mesure
que les problèmes évolué deviennent plus
aiguë et son ressenti par les intéressés
d'une façon plus sensible et bien
évidemment ça conduit à des actions
revendicatives plus fort c'est ça le
rôle d'un syndicat est aussi l'attitude
des travailleurs quand ça va pas bon
donc ils disent ça va s'arranger si ça
s'arrange pas il décide de passer la
vitesse supérieure
c'est pas une nouveauté et deuxième
partie d'émission qui est quand même en
passant la vitesse supérieure est ce que
vous prenez pas de risque de
déstabiliser le gouvernement
c'est là que j'ai compris c'est cet
aspect là mais je dirais ça ne peut pas
être ça qui détermine de toute façon
l'action d'un syndicat quel qu'il soit
en france quelques je comprenais tels
que je comprends les choses dans notre
pays qui a pas une organisation
syndicale est la cgt pas plus qu'une
autre j'irai peut-être moins que
d'autres
la cgt le ce depuis de se déterminer à
partir de considérations politiques nous
ne sommes pas indifférents à la
situation politique aux événements
politiques mais un syndicat il existe
pour défendre des intérêts des gens quel
que soit le gouvernement et je dirais on
ne peut pas critiquer l'absence de
syndicats
jouant le rôle de contrepoids ailleurs
qu'une voie lactée et de l'est par
exemple et demandé qu'ils agissent 1
chez nous faut accepter chez nous ce
qu'on souhaite
ailleurs c'est bien je vois juste inc il
faut dans toute société
même dans un système qui correspond
mieux à ce que je souhaite pour la
france et il n'y a pas de modèle à ce
sujet là mais je pense vraiment que le
syndicat il en faudra toujours un il en
faudra toujours un parce que il faut un
contrepoids qui soit l'expression de là
volonté direct des gens concernés c'est
normal ceux qui sont chargés de
fonctions de direction ils ont leurs
soucis même
même quand ils n'ont pas une mauvaise
intention à plus forte raison quand il
ya des oppositions d'intérêts là mais
même quand il n'y a pas une mauvaise
intention
ils ont leurs soucis il faut des gens et
les les intéressés eux mêmes les
salariés donc qui ce groupe
et puis qui dit ça va pas qu'ils
défendent leurs intérêts et syndicats il
a pour cela qu'il peut y avoir un seul
avion est rare de pouvoir de notre zone
asie un qui tient sa légitimité du
nombre et l'autre qui tient sa
légitimité de la compétence
bon bah alors faut décider qui appuient
le syndicat à quoi bon pourquoi on a
autorisé sa vie à bord est autorisé
parce que on les a conquis sa fallu se
battre venus battre 1 un siècle après la
révolution française mais le problème
c'est le premier choix industriels on y
reviendra tout à l'heure alors donc je
disais alors parce que je veux répondre
à cette question je pense qu'on y
reviendra sûrement aux aspects
politiques
le pire qui puisse arriver par dessus le
marché
la gauche en france c'est d'avoir
tellement déçu jusqu'au bout ceux qui
lui ont fait confiance qui lui tourne le
dos mieux vaut en plus de la défense des
revendications
mieux vaut quand des travailleurs sont
mécontents qu'il le soit en se fâchant
plutôt que de voter avec leurs pieds sur
les éclairs à l'orgue et claisse
lucrèce directeur de la rédaction du
matin bon un quart d'heure qui vous
venez de dire justement que le syndicat
ne se déterminait pas en fonction
déterminée uniquement fonction des
intérêts des travailleurs non pas en
fonction de la politique du gouvernement
mais vous n'avez pas toujours tenues
tout à fait ce langage tout de suite
après la victoire de la gauche en 1981
vous disiez justement qu'il fallait que
les travailleurs aident le gouvernement
ou 10e une interview jura sous les yeux
ce que vous la lire cl d'hier est lé du
31 juillet 1981 vous disiez l'équipe
gouvernementale se heurte à des
difficultés considérables une résistance
du capital et des pressions extérieures
les travailleurs doivent l'aider il faut
être le contrepoids des résistances et
des pressions et même si nécessaire du
gouvernement lui-même alors raté l'aider
au besoin le combattant je veux bien
dans cimpor
on avait les gants il fallait l'aider
quand même oui c'est vous venez de lire
et de graver ya lui-même
oui marion vous poser une question de
chars de la est ce qu'aujourd'hui vous
êtes vous avez toujours envie d'aider ce
gouvernement où est ce que vous êtes
décidé à le combattre
alors la position de la cgt par rapport
au gouvernement n'a pas changé dans son
principe ni dans la réflexion qu'il
conduit
nous avons pris note du changement de
gouvernement points à l'aller dernier
changement du dernier changement de
gommes en point à la ligne
est-ce que vous ne vous sentez une avant
nous n'avons pas modifié notre attitude
à l'égard du gouvernement
nous décidons nous l'avons fait nous
l'avons dit d'agir en fonction des
événements des actes concrets
je dis même pas jugés ou un chien poète
juge nous déterminons notre action de
syndicats d'après les actes de ce que
nous avons devant nous que ce soit le
gouvernement dont nous souhaitons que ce
soit des actes positifs pour les
travailleurs
où que je sois le cnpf nous nous savons
bien que la nos intérêts sont en
complète opposition
donc nous n'avons pas changé de position
de principe à l'égard de google
ce qui se modifie ce sont les événements
quand on nous quand on accentue le
blocage des salaires quand on nous
prépare un budget comme celui qui
s'annonce
quand on nous annonce que on a trop de
on a trop tôt on a trop de lait on a
trop de raisin on a trop d'à fier on a
trop de bras on a trop de cerveau n'a
trop de jeunes
et puis il faut faire des enfants quand
même trois enfants dans ces conditions
d'inondation
quand on nous dit tout ça qu'est-ce que
vous voulez qu'on fasse nous comme
syndicat des travailleurs et jeudi tous
les travailleurs
quelle que soit leur catégorie
professionnelle là ils sont tous
concernés
eh bien nous sommes bien obligés de dire
ça va pas tout quand ils y perdent en
pouvoir d'achat et big anti g y sont des
centaines de milliers à se demander de
quoi demain sera fait et quand ils sont
jeunes vous rendez compte la situation
faudrait peut-être qu'on parle de la
situation des jeunes auparavant je vais
revenir quand même à l'aspect un peu
politique du débat vous dites on
détermine en fonction des événements
hors tout de même il est un des
événements importants de l'été dernier
ça a été le départ des ministres
communistes du gouvernement vous henri
krasucki secrétaire général de la cgt
mais aussi comme le rappelait virieu
membre du bureau politique du parti
communiste est ce que vous ne savez ce
que vous ne vous sentez pas plus à
l'aise plus libéré pour agir maintenant
qu'il n'ya plus de ministres communistes
au gouvernement
je me suis senti libre tout le temps
alors je vous prête plus libre mais
seules limites
ce sont les possibilités réelles ce que
pensent les travailleurs ceux qui se
sentent capables de faire jusqu'à quel
point on peut agir et aussi les
événements concrètes et tient compte des
rapports de force de ce que font les uns
et les autres mais ça c'est le réalisme
tout simple de la conduite d'une
organisation syndicale
mais à aucun moment nous n'avons été
privés de notre liberté de syndicalisme
il n'y avait jamais de conflit entre
dans la tête d'henri krasucki entre le
secrétaire général
dubourg donne actuelle me semble
parfaite harmonie avec moi-même parce
que je me suis efforcé tout au long des
deux porte paroles avec mes camarades
des intérêts des travailleurs
vu comme une organisation syndicale
comme nous devons le faire vous me posez
cette question moi je lui réponds
volontiers mais est-ce que vous me
permettez ce sera pas très long parce
que je voudrais vous parler de la
situation des gens où ils disent est
important mais vous devez vous vous
devez le savoir mais quand même tout le
monde ne sais pas moi comme vous le
rappelez normal j'ai connu deux mois je
suis communiste
mais la cgt n'est pas comme essayer des
membres du bureau gnome et de rappeler
dans le mythe et sans bavure mais secret
s'il vous plaît là j'ai une réponse
importante et c'est une information pour
beaucoup de gens peut-être pour vous
aussi votre pour beaucoup de gens la cgt
en tant qu'organisation n'est pas
communiste
elle n'est pas non plus anti communiste
elle déploie davantage antisocialistes
ou anti paix sous ou anti aménagé par
rapport aux partis de droite ou
conservateurs naturellement on voit bien
les problèmes qui peuvent nous séparer
compte tenu de ce que nous sommes et des
débuts que nous proposons et de ce que
sont ces formations mais néanmoins dans
la vie réelle même de nos organisations
comme pour être à la cgt on ne vous
présente pas de passeport politique il
faut vouloir défendre ses intérêts il ya
dans la cgt beaucoup de personnes qui
votent même autrement qu'à gauche pour
aucun des partis de gauche et nous les
respectons et nous tenons à ce qu'ils
soient respectés dans notre organisation
alors par exemple j'ai ici permise et
mes invités je me permet de les
présenter c'est rapide c'est une partie
des membres du bureau contre de
compétences j'ai la moitié est bien
représentative il y avait bernard
lacombe ouvrier électricien là c'est pas
le convoi mais bernard lacombe ouvrier
électricien et prêtre ouvrier louis
viannet postiers et communiste
responsable monde du bureau politique du
parti comme
lydia brovelli cadre de l'assurance qui
n'appartient à aucune organisation
politique gérard baud mes ingénieurs en
informatique membre du comité directeur
du parti socialiste alain obadia
ingénieur à la ratp et secrétaire
général de l'union des ingénieurs cadres
et techniciens cgt communiste jean
claude larose j'en ai jean claude larose
agents de maîtrise de l'edf qui a eu les
engagements politiques qui aujourd'hui
n'appartient à aucune formation
politique et jeanine marre est qu'ils
aient une technicienne de la métallurgie
et qui n'appartient à aucune
organisation politique c'est ça la cgt
d'accord mais que vous n'avez je suis
leur secrétaire général monsieur
krasucki je trouve cette démonstration
cette démonstration 13 est très
intéressante mais quand même on peut
prendre la proposition en sens inverse
disons que la plupart des militants
communistes qui ce syndic ce syndicat la
cgt oui ou non
voilà je trouve et tous les autres tous
les autres nous on ne me repousse
personnes je souhaite mais nous allons
parler heureusement revue la situation
des joueurs ne m'en général donc qui
influent sur la situation des gens
disent que la politique économique du
gouvernement fait le niveau de vie la
situation économique de chacun alors
vous avez condamné complètement le
budget prévu pour 1985 j'avais dit qu'il
n'y avait rien de bon non bon alors je
voudrais simplement vous poser une
question qu'est ce qui est bon qu est ce
qui reste de bons à vos yeux
dans la politique du gouvernement
aujourd'hui je pose pas la question en
ces termes parce que je voulais dire tu
alors maintenant je veux moi je la
poserai vous me la poser mais une fois
vous ai posé la question je vous
expliquer comment j'y réponds mais pour
y répondre il faudrait encore que je me
pose la question comme vous le faites
hors nouvelles à cgt nous avons
décidé de ne pas nous nous astreint
actuellement à une évaluation globale et
permanente de ce qu'est de toute la
politique du gouvernement pour ainsi que
nous déterminons parce que nous ne
voulons pas nous déterminer le comme une
formation politique mais comme un
syndicat gouvernement il est ce qu'il
est ce qui nous importe c'est au plan
qui intéresse l'action syndicale donc
essentiellement les questions
économiques et sociales
le domaine fondamental d'accueil je vous
parle bah oui mais c'est pourquoi je me
limite à ces questions là qu'est ce que
nous pensons de telle ou telle décision
qui est prise
le budget ça va pas c'est vrai et la
politique industrielle et mesures
industrielles
ça va pas non plus vous dirais que ça
fait des gros des gros problèmes
ah oui ça fait des gros problème est
alors sacré non seulement un désaccord
mais sont des sources de conflits joue
pas le seul à les dire parce que vous
vous c'est normal vous m'interrogez -
vous avez l'avis de la cgt
citez moi un dirigeants d'organisations
syndicales aujourd'hui qui disent du
point de vue du constat quelque chose de
fondamental fondamentalement différent
de ce que je vous le dis en ce moment
moi j'entends ou je lis les déclarations
de certains de mes collègues qui
dirigent d'autres centrales syndicales
et ils font le même constat
certains disent enfin à force de tirer
sur la corde ça va finir par le nez des
mauvais résultats quand les gens sont
pas contents force d'être mécontent il
se produit des rédactions et ce qui
explique ce qui se passe chez renault
j'ai lu ça aujourd'hui sous la plume
d'andré bergeron bons rails on n'est pas
forcément d'accord sur tout mais c'est
le bon sens moi aussi j'ai le même bon
sens d'ailleurs nous il ya quelque chose
de très différent mais aussi quelque
chose de commun nous sortons de la même
souche
historiquement parlant mais d'autres
aussi
alors donc revenons à ce budget est
plutôt à ce que ressentent les gens
d'abord je parle pour qui je m'adresse à
tout le monde naturellement mais je me
sens le porte-parole de qui des
travailleurs salariés quel que soit leur
catégorie
c'est le rôle d'un syndicat ouvriers
employés techniciens
mur je me sens le porte parole des
chômeurs pour moi pour nous ce sont des
travailleurs privés d'emploi
je me sens le porte parole des retraités
et des préretraités
je me sens le porte parole aussi de
cette jeunesse qui n'est pas encore au
travail mais qui se demandent à l'issue
de ses études
quand il quand elle va ouvrir la porte
de sortie de l'école quelle va être la
hauteur de la marche
d'où ils vont nous elle va tomber porte
parole de tous mon gland et alors qu'est
ce qu'ils ressentent ces gens-là ça
représente
c'est ça représente quand même
l'essentiel de la population active du
pays et même au delà puisqu'il des
retraités qu'est ce qu'ils ressentent
ces gens là ils ont beaucoup espéré ils
ont eu raison qu'ils ont voulu quelque
chose et aujourd'hui
eh bien il trouve le contraire de ce
qu'ils vont souhaiter
il ne ressort qui a une crise le temps
des mets pas de faire un hommage ou quoi
mais ne commencez pas à expliquer aux
gens que je vous demande si vous
considérez que énormément compris
limitent la marge d'action du
gouvernement
oui mais moi je commence par vous dire
monsieur monsieur classe je vais vous
dire la raison qui me fait insisté un
peu et ne le prenez pas mal mais depuis
hier
j'entends aux informations des discours
politiciens qui me scandalise
de quoi parle-t-on en matière politique
on parle de magouilles pour les
élections législatives qui vont avoir
lieu dans un an et demi pour les
élections présidentielles qui vont avoir
lieu en 88 mais moi vous préoccupe pas
du tout c'est pas le problème
moi je pense avec les gens et
aujourd'hui comment y vivent
comment est-ce qu'ils s'en sortent de
quoi ont-ils besoin
comment peuvent-ils aider défendre leurs
intérêts comment peuvent-ils améliorer
leur sort comment peuvent-ils faire
survivre leur espoir parce qu'ils
étaient justifiées à dire que vous
estimez que la conquête du pouvoir
politique n'est finalement plus un moyen
de changer l'âge des choses ça suffit
pas à le considérer que ça suffisait
d'abord ça dépend de l'usagé qu'on en
fait et deuxièmement ça suffit pas
encore faut-il prendre des mesures qui
correspondent à skis
nécessaire pour modifier parce que tout
de même bon bain même en allant aussi
vite que possible
je lui ai dit tout à l'heure pour tous
les salariés
le pouvoir d'achat a baissé pour les
retraités pour les retraités aussi pour
les chômeurs mais je vais vous parler
c'est encore nagui 600000 mes nouveaux
pauvres
c'est plus que ça ceux qui n'ont plus
d'indemnisation et oui c'est justement
la cgt section coup manifestants si vous
le faites à ma place je vais bien vous
non non on peut changer
tu vois je remarque vous lance il avait
neigé jusqu'à présent vous lancez une
grande chance de sièges et avait lancé
vous revoir et à ma place ça va être une
grande bataille dans une grande
entreprise nationale kyrnos il semble ce
soit un conflit exemplaires à vos yeux
aujourd'hui n'ont pas recommencé pamela
de réponse sur une prime géant voici sur
une prime de 3 2 300 francs et sur la
5eme l'utilisation de la cinquième
semaine de congés payés
bon je m'étonne que vous lanciez un
conflit sur ce thème au moment où il ya
des sujets peut-être plus grave plus
douloureux et dont vous parlez très peu
comme précisément et les 600000 sommer
ben je regrette la zone journal
effectivement elle peut fait écho à une
déclaration que j'ai fait à ce sujet a
déjà quelques temps c'était au mois
d'opération ce n'est pas une action abba
naturellement ah bah quand on fait une
action il paraît que c'est pas bien et
puis ma général quand on en fait pas
c'est pas bien non plus alors je sais
plus ce qu'il faut faire quand je vous
entends j'ai adoré me répondait lors
donc je disais donc le pouvoir d'achat
ça va pas mais en plus le chômage
augmente
deux millions et demi environ et on va
vers les 3 millions la lure où les
choses vont même chichi on déguise par
des fonds que je n'aime pas beaucoup et
apparaît ce phénomène de la pauvreté
vous savez vous parliez de 600000 veille
si vous lisiez la cgt vous vous seriez
informé parce que nous le chiffre exact
c'est un million cent trente mille
j'ai parlé des nouveaux rôles à ce qu'il
a dit ça j'ai fait cela que je parle un
million en cendres 31 mille chômeurs ne
touche plus aucune indemnité plus un sou
rien d'aucune sorte
parmi eux alors ils vivent pour les uns
dans leur famille avec l'aide de leurs
amis ils n'ont pas de ressources et ils
sont en âge de travailler et ils sont
inscrits comme demandeurs d'emploi
il existe oui c'est le double du chiffre
que vous brûlez alors qu'est-ce qui
vient la cgt ces domaines
alors ces gens là est ce que vous vous
rendez compte de leur situation et parmi
eux il y a beaucoup de jeunes parce que
ils peuvent pas être indemnisées
longtemps je ne touche pas beaucoup
d'argent
et j'ajoute parmi ceux qui sont
indemniser les chômeurs vous savez qu'il
y en a un tiers un tiers des chômeurs
indemnisés qui touchent seulement 40
francs par jour par jour sans oui a
lille 200 franchement moi rendez juste
une pelle à vous rendez compte de ce que
ça représente les gens vivent ainsi de
nos jours une question c'est rasic qui
est-ce qui se tourne vers vous alors ces
jeunes si démunis est ce qu'ils savent
pas ce qu'ils vont vers la cgt ou est-ce
qu'il n'y croit une croix plus
ordination syndicale est ce que j'ai le
sentiment partie oui que vous avez une
clientèle vente par une clientèle je
n'aime pas le mot c'est pas après les
adhérents éventuelle des gens intéressés
ça c'est autre chose bien la jeunesse
vous avez ici les jeunes pas très
syndicalisés vous avez ici des jeunes
qui sont des militants actifs à la tête
de commission de la jeunesse dans des
entreprises les militants de la cgt il
ya des jeunes heureusement qu'il ya
parmi eux des chômeurs qui anime deux
comités de chômeurs mission mais invité
ce soir mais nous nous efforçons de
rassembler ces jeunes et il est vrai que
mais c'est un drame national
quand un jeune sur deux un jeune sur
deux en âge de travailler et soient
chômeurs soit dans une situation de
travail précaires c'est une tragédie
pour un pays un pays qui ne sait pas
quoi offrir à sa jeunesse il est en
danger le pays en tant que tel
il faut prendre des choses à 7 à ses
dimensions là comment s'étonner que ces
jeunes se pose énormément de questions
et se demandent mais comment je vais
m'en sortir
alors à eux nous avons quelque chose à
dire naturellement il ne vieillit force
en dire long courrier comme sa jeune
pour pauvres pour l'inviter à venir la
cgt là comme ça je lui raconterai je lui
raconterai unis une histoire vécue tout
dernièrement à l'alstom du bourget qui
est une ville importante
il ya une école d'apprentissage il ya
douze apprentis qui sont sortis de cette
école d'apprentissage et qui risquaient
de se retrouver chômeur grâce au
syndicat cgt de l'usiné et à la
commission des jeunes cgt de l'usiné de
l'alstom du bourget les douze ont un
travail sur les 12
il y en a huit qui sont embauchés l
usine 2 qui poursuivent leurs études
pour un bts donc venir des techniciens
et deux qui ont été embauché dans une
entreprise voisine
c'est un petit gang il est isolé comme
acquise les baisser ses salles
syndicaliste c'est faire ça partout le
syndicat est née de ce que entreprise
par entreprise
là où les gens existent ils se sont
organisés
il ya eu la solidarité de l'entrée c'est
très beau et c'est de ces petits fruits
sont là qu'est née la cgt la syrie
thévenez longtemps après que les
premiers syndicats se sont formés
petitement boîte par boîte vous ça la
vérité monsieur reste je leur dis ça et
en même temps je leur dis mais
naturellement qu'on doit pouvoir faire
autre chose c'est pas normal à notre
époque de considérer que la société
n'est que ça à offrir et à une jeunesse
et et à tout un peuple à tous ceux qui
veulent travailler
il ya donc forcément d'autres solutions
mais ça nous pousse tout le problème
justement et de la politique
industrielle je sais pas si nous pouvons
en discuter mais sucrant 200 dernières
qui c'est une grande question que faire
pour avoir une industrie française parce
que finalement le chômage frôle yamada
qui sonnerait d or soit y'a rien à faire
messieurs krasucki comparer justement à
ce drame énorme des jeunes sans emploi
ce que vous croyez que la situation des
ouvriers de
vironneau justifie de déclencher des
grèves qui peuvent mettre en péril le
lancement d'un nouveau modèle et la
situation d'une entreprise aussi
importante que renault je voudrais pas
qu une disproportion là mais s'il ne se
bat pas ça fera encore des dizaines de
milliers de chômeurs en plus qui va y
gagner
ça va faire embaucher un seul jeune
chômeur ça c'est leur lutte qui peut
créer des emplois qui n'existe pas
actuellement
c'est précisément pour ça que je disais
tout à l'heure à alain duhamel
nous nous proposons pas seulement la
régie renault nous proposons à l'échelle
du pays
parlons modernisation dit ce qu'on nous
dit modernisons il faut que nos amis de
la france
vous étiez pour 1 je suis toujours cours
mais sans toucher à rien ni aux emplois
ni auxerre continue et non mais est-ce
que vous allez sur les moyens de la
modernisation selon vous vous êtes
contre les réductions d'effectifs
j'ai entendu votre question mais si vous
considérez que je ne pourrais pas y
répondre
quels sont les moins vite sur les moyens
en suite on passait ce gps que tout de
même qu'elle a les moyens
ils sont plusieurs 1 ils sont denses
financier parce que c'est vrai pour pour
refaire et développer et moderniser une
industrie française il faut des
investissements qui paye la question est
là où est la justice actuellement
où est la justice les gens ne la voit
pas et comment voulez-vous qu'il l'avoué
j'ai eu l'occasion de le dire on a des
formes aimant chiffres parce que il a
paru tellement inexactes et pourtant
c'est la vérité pure pour seulement se
repérer avec la sphère de la promesse de
réduction des impôts ça fera 12 francs
50 pour les petits de réduction mais
pour les plus fortunés
notez-bien 500 mille francs je dis bien
francs actuels 500 mille francs de
déductions vous rendez compte ce que ça
représente comme comme niveau de 0 50
centimes faruck millions tandis
simplement de le déduction c'est
phénoménal donner une idée de ce que
c'est j'ai fait un calcul
vous le présentez maintenant c'est
impossible c'est bien dommage mais j'ai
fait un calcul
combien de générations il faut vanille
seulement 1 milliard de centimes 1 6
milliard il faut cinq générations
mais même un un ingénieur qui gagnent 15
mille francs par mois
sa carrière ni sud en mai sur
l'inégalité ces photos de carrière c'est
peu carrière d'ingénieur pour pour pour
y arriver donc alors mais l'argent
existe tout le monde n'est pas pauvre il
ya des pauvres en france mais la france
n'est pas un pays pauvre et tout le
monde n'y ait pas pauvre les dizaines et
quelques dizaines de milliards qu'il
faudrait pour financer voilà un premier
problème
deuxième point lusage l'usagé qu'on en
fait c'est à dire l'efficacité
parce qu'il ya énormément de gâchis
énorme gaspillage et parmi ces
gaspillages et bien il ya le fait que
est ce que vous vous rendez compte qu'on
est en train de fermer des choses tout à
fait moderne est tout à fait nécessaire
je circule heureusement que je circule
j'ai visité en moyenne depuis deux ans
au moins une entreprise par mois prise
dans des régions différentes et dans des
branches différentes
la visite comporte est d'abord une
visite technique conduit par les replis
représentants de la direction les
techniciens j'ai vu des choses
admirables et des gens qui veulent
parfaitement leurs affaires dans
certains cas du meilleur niveau européen
et même mondial mais plus rangée vu sa
tante par antar et titube bon jeu gta
creusot loire 8 jours avant le dépôt de
bilan
pas rentable rose ou noir abba
parlons-en oui parce que c'est un
excellent temps puisqu'en baryton par
des idées bien on verra tout à l'heure
je suis sûr qu'en vivant je suis reconnu
qu albert durand moi je suis surpris
parce que non halal parce qu'on y est et
on parlera avec albert du roy de la
technique c'est reed race et pavement
s'il veut bien tu veux bien mais je
pense à voile appelle naturellement mes
semis obligé de faire ainsi creusot
loire qui sont les propriétaires
trois familles en pin chine aïder de
vindelle peut pas dire que il ya
personne dans cette salle qui correspond
à ce profil là c'est vraiment les
grandes fortunes c'est la grande fortune
française c'est aussi les champions du
libéralisme c'est ce qu'ils nous disent
laissez nous faire nous nous allons vous
montrer ce que c'est que l'esprit
d'entreprise nous nous allons vous
montrer comment on gère les entreprises
creusot loire
c'est un ensemble ultra moderne un outil
comme il n'y a à peu au monde en
mécanique lourde est extrêmement
spécialisé j'ai visité j'ai vu et j'ai
entendu les ingénieurs ils m'ont
expliqué que y'a rien de mieux au monde
on trouve l'équivalent ne trouve pas
mieux et c'est ça qui est en train de
qui est temps qu'ils risquent de
disparaître
et si les travailleurs cesse ou ralenti
si peu que ce soit leur lutte
effectivement cet outil risque de
disparaître
on n'a pas de comptes à leur demander à
ces gens là si c'est pour voir vous vous
rendez compte que les deux vindelle les
schneider et les et les enfin ils vont
avoir une déduction d'impôt phénoménal
en plus en prime ils ont cassé lusine
ils se sont enrichis
ils vont mettre les gens à la porte qui
vont priver la france de d'une vaste
entreprise de premier ordre
ils vont encore trouver un avantage si
vous trouvez ça normal donc je disais il
ya l'usagé qu'on en fait et puis on
s'est alors par si on parle de
modernisation moi je veux bien qu'on en
parle on va je vais proposer qu'on le
laisse pour votre collègue alors
d'accord c'est bien d'accord des
solitudes souris sans merci qui classe
alors retour asvp jean-louis la scène
oui beaucoup de questions de
téléspectateurs sur la pologne et vos
origines polonaises monsieur krasucki
pour moi d'être vous jamais présents
dans les manifestations en faveur de la
pologne
comment se fait-il qu étant secrétaire
de la cgt secrétaire général de la cgt
vous êtes contre un syndicat libre en
pologne et enfin monsieur krasucki
pense-t-il qu'il pourrait d'entreprendre
les mêmes actions en pologne en france
tout d'abord
laissons là la question de mes origines
je crois être un citoyen français qui
accomplit son devoir de français
moi et les miens par conséquent ce n'est
pas un problème d'origine
vous pouvez poser la même question au
cardinal lustiger
il allait même origine que moi mais
personne ni insistent trop je souhaite
que on est à l'égard du syndicaliste la
même élégance qu'à l'égard du cardinal
maintenant pour ce qui est alors des
problèmes concernant la pologne
j'observe que ce pays qui a
effectivement payé cher le fait qu'il a
notamment mené une politique syndicale
qui faisait que les syndicats n'avaient
pas d'existence réelle ce que la cgt a
critiqué en son temps on s'en souvient
bien
la pologne a traversé une crise
effroyable allah était même au bord du
gouffre elle est à peine convalescente
je vois comment les autorités polonaises
comment l'épiscopat polonais ses forces
avec la société polonaise de trouver des
chemins pour pour faire quelque chose
pour refaire une pologne une pologne qui
soit qu'ils soient mieux qu'ils soient
mieux qu est ce qu elle était aussi du
point de vue syndical
je vois que tout le monde observe un
comportement
disons plus prudents à l'égard de la
pologne
que ce soit les responsables d'état même
reggane n'en commence à parler autrement
la cgt a suivi très soigneusement les
événements de pologne
personne ne pouvait comme organisations
syndicales être plus touché profondément
touché par ce que nous avions des vieux
liens d'amitié entre les deux pays mais
aussi entre les deux classes ouvrières
entre les organisations syndicales par
ce qui est arrivé là-bas mais la
question était que vous témoigner ici
mais nous l'avons fait à notre façon
l'enfer notre façon qui est de
rechercher à éviter d'envenimer les
choses
mais plutôt de favoriser une évolution
qui des choses étant ce qu'elles sont
dans ce pays là nous nous sommes en
france nous sommes pas là bas pour
parler des affaires des polonais à leur
place mais les inciter à des choses qui
conduirait le pays bas là où il n'a pas
voulu finalement aller c'est pas non
plus notre rôle n'était ni drury vivant
le suivant attentivement ce qui se
passait nous souhaitons vraiment que ce
pays se refasse et qu'il se refasse avec
des syndicats authentique
il y avait une autre partie de la
question pensez vous que vous pourriez
avoir le même type d'action dans un pays
de l'est
la pulsion messieurs m'est venu à
l'esprit les jeunes ils ont une certaine
passion de voir les choses
nous nous sommes en france sur les
questions syndicales on sait qu'il ya eu
pas mal de divergences que nous avons
exprimé mais je voudrais dire que en
même temps on dit des choses pas très
réaliste et pas très raisonnable voilà
la france
une autre tradition une autre histoire
nous avons une autre façon de concevoir
l'avenir pour notre pays c'est bien
connu et je le redis cela étant quand on
regarde les pays socialistes quand on
veut y voir
je pense qu'on dit à la longue vous
savez il ya des gens qui me font penser
j'ai entendu dire dernièrement que je
veux voir fleurir des choses du genre
ils savent rien faire ils viennent
copier pour la technique pour ceux ci
pour cela et ça me rappelle j'ai vécu
assez pour
connaître ça ça me rappelle ce qui se
raconte et au début des années 50 sur
sur l'union soviétique c'était des
deschamps qui tu fais pour lire des gens
qui savent et qui savait rien qui avait
rien et c'est surtout une technique
complètement ignan puis un bon jour ils
sont retrouvés gaillard in dans l'espace
et et comme il y avait personne d'autre
avant c'étaient bien les premiers il
avait pris à personne puisque personne
n'avait su le faire alors les mêmes il a
fallu expliquer comment ce peuple de
crétins d'abrutis d'analphabètes et a
été capable de faire ça alors c'est la
même chose pour beaucoup dans beaucoup
de domaines soyons prudents tout
simplement je ne demande pas moi je suis
pas là pour pour faire la publicité
c'est pas ça
l'information une information objective
on peut trouver bien ou mal telles
choses ou tel autre nous y sommes allés
tenir avec gérard mais nous étions
délégation syndicale
on a vu des choses intéressantes les
choses intéressantes et puis en même
temps bon ben on pense pas avoir eu
réponse à tout mais c'est pas l'enfer
c'est autre chose parce que à notre
époque les relations internationales
devraient pas être qu'on essaye d'en
faire cesser cette guerre froide et
c'est l'embrouillé tous ses commandants
comment avez-vous réagi vous
personnellement à l'emprisonnement de
notre confrère jacques bouchard par les
autorités afghanes
un dnca je peux vous le dire d'abord je
pense que il faut qu'il soit libéré dans
le plus rapidement possible meilleures
conditions je comprends la réaction je
vous l'avais bien dit qu'à des syndicats
de journalistes
j'ai apprécié le communiqué du quai
d'orsay qui a dit pour des affaires
délicates comme celle là si on veut être
efficace il faut savoir s'y prendre avec
un certain savoir faire
ben figurez vous que pour ce qui est de
la cgt dans la mesure de nos
possibilités
il se trouve que nous avons quelques
relations avec les syndicats
d'afghanistan nous avons fait de notre
part les démarches qui peut faciliter
utilement une issue positive
j'ignore si nous y parvenons nous y
parviendrons
et nous l'avons fait que bien alors
albert derom
pardon mais je vais lui en prit je vais
vous rim est scandaleusement en vous
posant des questions et éventuellement
vous n'auriez pas souhaitez-vous voir ce
que vous avez décidé un peu à l'avant
cela des questions que je devais banon
je vais l'aborder quelques autres ça
sera comme vous voulez cinq ans qui
posait la question
deux questions le mans vous signale
c'est seulement une suggestion que je me
permets de vous faire parce que ça me
paraissait intéressant quand même le
problème du progrès technique
en france c'est une idée des questions
des questions que je pensais
intéresseront qu'elle est aussi mêlée
mais si mais si vous venez pas me la
pose et je répondrai pas d'accord moi
tout ce que je demande c'est que vous
répondiez à mes questions
vous pouvez y compter les voilà d'abord
deux questions d'ordre un peu général
sur ce qui se passe souvent dans des
conflits du travail quand un service
public se met en grève la sncf la ratp
les ptt
contre qui sait-on grève on fait d'abord
grève pour quelque chose
on fait grève parce qu'on en a besoin
d'une amélioration de salaire des
conditions de travail ou d'un peu plus
de liberté le droit à la parole
aujourd'hui les revendications c'est
plus large contre x mais une grève c'est
censé mettre en difficulté et en dévot
dame nature mais vu mais c'est d'abord
parce qu'on veut quelque chose à kraft
donc j'ai pas on veut pas faire du mal
on veut on veut obtenir du bien c'est
pas la même chose et on commence pas par
faire la grève
on commence par le demander on commence
même par le demander poliment avec
déférence
heureusement grâce à l'action syndicale
depuis 1936 seulement il ya des délégués
du personnel avant c'est pas vieux
avant il fallait que chacun ait demandé
pour soit une augmentation s'est pas
fait agréable d'aller trouver son patron
pour le dire je veux d'augmentation faut
déjà un certain presque du courage
ben on a maintenant des délégués qui
peuvent parler pour vous bon alors on le
fait quand c'est non ben et finit sa vie
va arriver au conflit quand on n'a pas
le choix on fait une grève et à ce
moment là ben oui un conflit s'étend
free c'est un conflit d'intérêt quand
les travailleurs n'ont pas d'autre
solution ils font la grève
eh bien ils font la grève contre leur
employeur celui qui leur refuse ce
qu'ils ont demandé la subit les
conséquences là je vois je vois très
bien où vous voulez en venir mais ceux
qui en subissent les conséquences ont
eux mêmes un jour besoin de demander à
leurs patrons quelque chose et de se
mettre en grève et par contre c'est quoi
ils sont capables de comprendre puis
mais en général d'ailleurs j'en profite
pour vous le dire parce que j'entends
des choses vais en ce moment à propos de
telle ou telle action sociale par
exemple renault ou d'eau je crois que ce
serait se méprendre sur l'état de
l'opinion de beaucoup de gens je ne
crois pas moi vous voyez que dans leur
majorité les gens ne comprennent pas
ceux qui manifestent pour leurs
revendications parce que tous en ont à
défendre et je crois qu'il ya plutôt une
tendance à une compréhension mutuelle
quand je vois les conflits récents au
creusot justement là tout le monde oui à
les ingénieurs il ya les commerçants il
ya les patrons de sous traitance parce
qu'ils vont crever les employés de ces
entreprises
tout le monde y est risque public etc
sont des gens comme les autres il est en
droit de se défendre et ils vont les
gens qui travaillent maintenant se
défendre est naturellement bon ben alors
faut pas le leur reprocher il faut
l'élever
il faudra le faire ils vont probablement
faire quelque chose de prochainement oui
l'épave est évidemment parce que ils ont
tellement suivi de d'atteinte à leur
niveau de vie on a tellement peu tenu
les engagements pris à l'oreille arc
tous tous avec leurs organisations
syndicales que ce soit à la cgt que ce
soit il faut que ce soit la fen et la
cfdt mais avec des nuances je crois
qu'il aura personne en dehors sont
amenés à prendre des initiatives
d'action n'entendait pas vous n'entendez
pas de décoder du mécontentement des
usagers
de l'enseignement ou de la sncf vous ne
pensez que ça ne traduit pas une réalité
bon j'ai eu quelques fois oui mais c'est
que selon francis merlin qui sont
perdants tant que mu s'est contenté
contribuables oui mais je connais
beaucoup de défenseurs des usagers qui
s'en prennent aux usagers quand ces
mêmes usagers défendre leurs propres
intérêts parce que il ya des gens qui
sont jamais contents quand les
travailleurs se défendre quelle que soit
leur catégorie
alors je crois avoir répondu à votre
question parce que le temps est court
pour des créations autres questions
d'ordre général
vous défendez vous avez raison
évidemment c'est un droit fondamental le
droit de grève
est-ce que vous approuvez lorsque
lorsque dans certains conflits des
grévistes font en sorte d'empêcher des
gens qui ne veulent pas à la grèce de
travailler comme ça arrive mais
actuellement c'est pas comme ça que ça
se passe mais c'est le cas de figure que
je voudrais oui mais j'aime pas discuté
d'une manière abstraite mais je suis
bien parce que c'est dieu que c'est pas
un problème concret nous mêmes ça dépend
ça dépend des situations qu'on est dans
le genre de choses et si qu'est ce que
vous faites si oui suppositions les
anglais disent ici m'attendais derosa
sur une bicyclette
je sais pas raisonner comme ça moi je
veux savoir de quoi il s'agit citez moi
citez moi une histoire précise je vous
dirai si je pense qu'ils ont bien fait
mal fait ce que le droit au travail le
droit de ne pas faire grève ça dépend
des cas parfois c'est respectable
parfois c'est pas respectable parce que
lire aussi parmi les travailleurs
la démocratie c'est aussi la loi de la
majorité alors est ce n'est pas
seulement la majorité décide de faire
grève la minorité n'a pas le droit de
stationner c'est pas une question
d'avoir le droit d'ailleurs à bas
actuellement chez nous enfin je connais
hier de deux situations de mouvements
importants où les grévistes majoritaire
et empêcher ceux qui voulaient
travailler dit elle
je connais pas de situation important
tant il ya peut-être eu ici vous la
savez il s'en passe des choses mais vous
prenez des pays voisins leurs traditions
c'est une discipline depuis qu'on nous
cite en exemple que ce soit l'allemagne
fédérale
que ce soit les pays scandinaves
la grande-bretagne il ya une discipline
absolue ça d'abord quelquefois le
syndicat est quasiment obligatoire
et quand ils décident une brève elle est
impérative et c'est la loi de la
majorité qui dessine chez nous ce bon
compte sont les pays vous n'aimez pas
qu'on vous cite en exemple d'habitude je
vous laisse y soyez content parce qu'en
terme de consensus m cela me dit ça vous
dit parce que on se trompe bonne sous
bien des aspects concernant le
syndicalisme en france et dans les pays
voisins et à travers le monde
c'est beaucoup plus compliqué compliqué
qu'il n'y paraît du point de vue en tout
cas de la question que vous me posez en
france dans le passéisme août du
problème de forcément mais dans le passé
il est arrivé des moments avec des
luttes difficiles mais où les
travailleurs ayant majorité décidé la
grève
il faisait ce qu'ils appelaient
défendent leur grève ça existait
actuellement c'est pas ça qui se produit
et je souhaite que le plus possible on
consulte les gens la cgt prône le vote
nous avons organisé sur renault mais
aussi ailleurs nous demandons qu'on
donne la parole aux travailleurs qu'ils
décident ce qu'ils veulent nous leur
faisons des propositions naturellement
des propositions de revendication de
solutions et au sidaction
mais la parole doit leur appartenir est
ce qu'on doit pas on peut pas avoir une
vision plus ouverte plus démocratique
que la conduite de l'action syndicale
ces années ce client un phénomène de
désyndicalisation en france actuellement
à wimbledon les chiffres justement sur
un chiffre concernant la cgt alors
quelles sont les causes il y en a qui
sont objectives jeunes et on parlerait
pas en premier parce que je ne voudrais
pas avoir l'air de chercher des faux
fuyants que des prétextes
c'est l'heure de vérité et 12 heures je
n'aime pas ne pas dire la vérité
donc je vais d'abord à ce qui me paraît
essentiel pour une part mais nous lisons
publiquement nous nous disons pour une
part les causes elles sont chez nous
pour une part dans quelque chose à dire
aussi à tous les travailleurs salariés
mais parlons d'abord balayons devant
notre porte oui parce que justement
c'est on peut se demander si vous gérez
une vous remettait pas en cause mais
justement c'est ce que je suis en train
de mourir alors puisque le temps nous
allons annoncer que je vous dise ce que
nous nous disons à nous mêmes oui nous
nous remettons en cause et pas
d'aujourd'hui heureusement parce que la
cgt est la plus grande est aussi la plus
ancienne des organisations syndicales 20
voire 90 ans l'année prochaine ça mais
mais elle et elle doit rester toujours
avec son temps donc elle doit évoluer
elle a énormément évolué je n'imaginais
nos fondateurs puisque nous faisons
aujourd'hui il ya quand même pas mal de
choses qui ont changé
arrivant automatique depuis et bien à
notre époque il se passe tellement de
choses il faut s'y adapter
nous avons fait nous avons modifié déjà
pas mal de choses par exemple du point
de vue des questions donc est-ce qu'il
est là parce que vous annoncez vous avez
vous avez dit je vais vous expliquer
mais j'ai entamé mi-mars de
responsabilité mais une ville à présent
vous ne retirez pas je suis en train de
le faire mais vous me manger mais
minutes
comme la mine de rien alors oui mais je
connais la technique c'est une technique
ah oui pour vous alors donc oui j'en
tiens compte mais je pourrais bien
laborieux de la période je pourrais pas
y répondre si vous permettez pas alors
donc nous avons entrepris effectivement
de dire voilà la cgt doit vivre avec son
temps ça veut dire quoi
à notre époque se produisent des
changements dans les professions dans
les qualifications résultant des
transformations techniques
il ya des catégories qui prennent qui
ont pris prendront encore plus une place
plus grande dans la vie industrielle
dans la vie économique d'un vivre
l'activité plus simplement syndicats qui
est née syndicats ouvriers
c'est comme ça ce sont les ouvriers qui
ont créé les syndicats il doit savoir
être aussi le syndicat des employés le
indique yade et les agents de maîtrise
le syndicat des ingénieurs des
techniciens
le syndicat déclare alors on n'a pas été
si nous le faisons nous faisons beaucoup
d'efforts pour ça et nous pensions qu'il
faut le faire plus encore et ne pas
craindre de regarder comment nous nous y
prenons pour faire sable et deuxièmement
l'entrée massive des femmes dans la
production et notamment de jeunes femmes
dans la production provoquer un ensemble
de phénomènes considérable et de bons
phénomène mais dans la vie à
l'entreprise dans les mentalités dans
les aspirations de ces femmes et dans
leurs revendications au droit à
l'égalité de responsabilité d'accès aux
professions et aussi aux rémunérations
et c'est bien il faut être le syndicat
de ces femmes d'aujourd'hui nous nous
efforçons de l'être est-ce que nous
sommes assez bons nous posons la
question franchement et nous la posons
pas seulement aux nôtres nous apposons
aux intéressés la jeunesse elle et elle
est aujourd'hui bas comme elle est
chaque génération pour comprendre qu on
dit quelquefois c'est difficile de
comprendre les jeunes
il suffit de se rappeler comment on
était au même âge ils sont différents
mais au même âge toutes les générations
ont eu tendance à vouloir faire
autrement que la génération d'avant et
bien donc je suis pas choqué par ça je
faisais une toute petite voyons soyons
comme on doit être le syndicat de ces
jeunes-là attendait alors oui ça fait
pas mal de choses à examiner une part
une parenthèse que c'est dans le dj
c'est dans le sujet quand vous dites il
faut être proche des femmes des gens du
jeune et herat est ce que le fait d'être
permanent comme vous l'êtes depuis très
longtemps
est ce que ce n'est pas un handicap
parce que vous ne risquez pas de perdre
le contact
justement avec ses réalités là pour moi
non pour moi là franchement non le le
jour
j'ai gardé mon âme de délayer du
personnel oui et vous êtes permanent
depuis quelques mois depuis
mais vous avez oublié tout à l'heure le
rappeler que j'avais un métier et de
l'exercer vous avez ajuste régis
ajusteur professionnels oui et comme
tous mes camarades mais pas tout dire à
un bonjour monsieur parent proche de
saisie pour l'occasion pour réparer ces
petits détails à côté comme tous mes
camarades donc j'ai gardé comme tous les
ans d'un homme un peu l'intérêt
d'adhérer yens ou là là je vais vous
dire je vous en parlais il ya combien de
permanents la cgt parce que quand vous
posez vous êtes en train de croiser les
tirs là et personne n'a plus rien
comprendre
c'est le prolongement de la question
j'essaye de répondre quoi l'appareil
j'essaye de répondre clairement à une
question qu'on essaie d'envoyer à leur
permettez moi de rester clair si je peux
la halle et le syndicaliste que je suis
et que sont mes camarades savez je reste
pas derrière mon bureau je suis je vis
dans une cité hlm je rencontre des gens
je vais bon beaucoup de réunions
syndicales et sur le terrain dans les
entreprises
j dispute avec les travailleurs les
syndics et les autres les responsables
naturellement nous efforçons après la
désyndicalisation voir ça on va y venir
et je souhaite que les autres le fassent
davantage encore et c'est ce que je fais
je vis comme ça je peux pas vivre
autrement
moi j'ai des copains dans toute la
france dans les usines les entreprises
toutes les catégories je m'efforce jeu
peut pas diriger autrement depuis
toujours mon activité mais maintenant je
vais vous dire deux mots des appareils
et puis au delà parce que j'avais
j'avais d'autres choses à dire sur ce
que nous demandons de remettre en
question chez nous comme je vois que le
temps s'écoule j'éprouve le besoin de
dire quelque chose je vous parlais
d'appareils en ce moment eux ont dit on
dit beaucoup de choses sur les syndicats
on s'adresse aux gens et notamment jaune
on leur dit mais qu'est ce que vous avez
besoin d'organisation qu'est ce que vous
faites mieux nous organiser
on a besoin de syndicats qui se faisait
à besoin d'appareil etc
sécher ses dents c est la mort de l'air
du temps on dit ça on dit ça outre aux
travailleurs salariés
mais est-ce que j'ai jamais entendu
quelqu'un d'entre vous le google des
commentateurs de ce qui pose ces
questions le dire au patron
est ce que quelqu'un dit aux patrons
mais qu'est-ce que vous avez besoin d'un
syndicat patronal qu'est-ce que vous
avez besoin
la cnpf qu'est-ce que vous avez besoin
d'appareil vous rendez compte que c'est
clos center rendez compte le nombre de
permanents qui là vous rendez compte
les gens qui payent qui sortent des
grandes écoles qui sont eux est
largement payé tout ça pour s'occuper
d'eux de serrer la vis aux travailleurs
parce que le cnpf easy sont tous il paye
de grosses cotisations même les
entreprises nationalisées mais ils y
sont tous bien que leurs intérêts sont
contradictoires ils s'entre déchirent
sur le plan des affaires
mais face aux travailleurs salariés une
forme bloc et là ils sont tous organisé
personne ne leur dit tu commences et
vieillot vos appareils et nous les
travailleurs nous les travailleurs
qu'ils soient organisés qu'ils le soient
pas nous nous devrions être dispersés
nous ne voudrions ne pas avoir
d'interlocuteur mouvoir des comptes que
pour être l'intérêt m'excuser mois
peugeot pas qui nous fait ce procès
parce que vraiment vraiment c'est pas la
classe que parce que nos rêves nous
monsieur gaston lui poser des questions
sur le cndf
vous dites vous dites on essaie de
s'adapter vous ai offensés non je le
retire parce que je ne veux pas
m'engager dans un débat avait commencé
quand même répondre aux questions si
vous dites depuis dix minutes avant mon
fardeau des appareils on se remet en
cause
et puis vous parler et vous ne vous ne
vous remettez pas en cause tout est
alors c'est difficile de discuter avec
vous dans ces conditions parce que
j'étais en train et c'est pas je pense
pas que ce soit par hasard vous m'avez
interrompu excusez moi de vous dire mais
j'étais en train de vous parler de ce
qu'on ne dit pas aux patrons et de ce
qui représente l'appareil pas trop mal
je répondais par là à ma manière à la
question que je me posais henri de
virieu parce que
moi je dois être l'interlocuteur des du
cnpf c'est une force
formidablement organisé et quand je dis
moi tu ne personnalise pas moi et mes
camarades dirigeants de la cgt
l'interlocuteur du premier ministre du
président de la république des plus
hautes autorités de l'état de
représentants des travailleurs à ce
niveau là et ensuite tous les niveaux
intermédiaires il y a du côté des
patrons du côté des pouvoirs publics
il y à des appareils formidable vous
prenez toutes les administrations et
alors les travailleurs eux et devrait
être là tout seul
démunis se débrouiller sans organisation
sans avoir des gens qui bien qu'il n'ait
pas eu la possibilité d'aller pour
beaucoup d'entre eux mêmes pour la
majorité d'entre eux de les suivre des
études prolongées
grâce à l'organisation acquièrent les
connaissances nécessaires pour pouvoir
faire jeu égal et défendre leurs
intérêts être leur porte parole pour
caler les hurricanes je ne parvienne pas
parviennent moins qu'avant vient faire
du temps alors que je réponds donc à la
question sur fondue en ses chances que
majeur brute a contrario quand sans
quelques puisque les patrons est un
énorme appareil
nous nous donnerons tout petit vous me
demandez combien y est permis si j'étais
à côté de l'appareil patronale ccc nous
nous faisons ça donne quelque personne
se ce qui ce se qui leur foi e pour
juste pas moi ils ont pris plusieurs
dizaines de personnes deux ou trois
c'est de cet ordre là dans les dents tel
ou tel service au total les noms de
permanence la cgt suisse de l'ordre de
2006 le maximum dans toute la france en
tenant compte des secrétaires d'unions
locales des départements du doubs du
loyer du plus petit duc au niveau
national c'est le maximum de ce que nous
ayons elle avec ça on fait jeu égal avec
l'énorme appareil d'état tous les
cabinets ministériels et surtout le cnpf
et et cette citadelle que ça représente
ça fait ça fait du bruit alors c'est ce
qui fait que j'ai répondu du même coup à
une autre aspect de votre question ça je
le dis aux travailleurs à tous les
travailleurs
ne vous laissez pas impressionner par ce
qu'on raconte sur ces problèmes là si le
syndicat n'est pas tel que vous le
voudriez ça nous acceptons la critique
nous sommes prêts à discuter avec vous
nous disons voyons ensemble parce que
personne ne peut faire un syndicat la
place des travailleurs nous en voyons
ensemble
qu'est-ce qui va pas faisons ensemble
syndicales qu'il vous faut nous ne
refusons aucune question le syndicat
représentant toutes les diversités et c
c'est ça quand vous dites je réponds pas
à la remise en cause mais si c'est une
remise en cause publique lisez ce que
nous avons déjà écrit mais vous allez
pouvoir lire dans notre journal la vie
ouvrière des choses intéressantes sur le
débat et les mesures que nous entendons
prendre pour que ces questions là soient
posées au grand jour dans les
entreprises
j'aurais voulu quand même vous entendre
dire ce qui à votre avis ne va pas dans
le syndicalisme tel qu'il fonctionne
c'est ce que je fais depuis tout à
l'heure je vous explique qu'il faut
s'adapter à des réalités nouvelles
et bien quand nous disons il faut s'y
adapter sa super ça suppose d'examiner
jusqu'à quel point ici ou là on s'est
vraiment adapté ou pas qu'est ce qui va
pas là comme un temps 1 il faudra quand
même temps il faut le temps qu'il faut
et je vous dis ça se planifie pas c'est
une organisation de bénévoles
c'est une organisation vous rendez
compte que des indications occasion de
volontaires et à notre époque avec la
manière de vivre d'aujourd'hui est quand
même de militer aujourd'hui et c'est
beau de cette façon là aussi parce que
ça demande un peu de générosité
ça demande un peu pourquoi pas besoin
d'être un héros sa demande de de sentir
que on s'en sortira pas tout seul que
lequel qu'elle conçoit ouvriers ou qu'on
soit ingénieur on en est pas moins homme
ou femme et salariés et on a des
intérêts à défendre et il faut y mettre
du sien mais y met du sien pour quelque
chose de beau puisqu'il s'agit de la
défense des intérêts de ceux qui font
des richesses du pays qui représente
l'avenir
vous avez encore vous avez le sentiment
de pouvoir dire je nous ce que ces
collectifs nous représentons
le monde des travailleurs va nous en
présentons une partie est pour
l'organisation
pour une bonne organisation qui n'en
finit pas de décliner
si j'entends les informations et tout ce
qu'on dit au sujet parce que nous
faisons chez renault roseau ou chantier
naval est jeune c'est ou encore c'est
une organisation qui compte dans la vie
du pays cela dit nous ne nous
satisfaisons pas vous êtes si tvo prenne
force pas seulement 38% effet 38%
dernières prud'homales
oui et vous avez baissé de 5 points par
rapport aux prud'homales précédente ils
étaient cinq ans avant naturellement
ligne alagna d'école pouvoir l'avons dit
non je dis pas un déclin jeudi pékin
quand tu as un recul momentané pas la
même chose mais mais cela dit je crois
bien ne pas mettre des robes et à la
question essentielle est ce que la cgt
contente de ce qu'elle est non flash qui
est ce qu'elle est content de comment
elle fonctionne non est ce que l a
quelque chose à cacher non est ce
qu'elle dit examinant les choses au
grand jour dans les entreprises avec
tous les travailleurs concernés
oui nous essayons de le faire est-ce que
nous rendons sa public
oui vous y avez accès des journalistes
vous nous vous en donnerons l'occasion
de le voir davantage encore jason bien
j'ai beaucoup d'idées à cet égard et
c'est un gars que je vous dis qu'on va
pas épuiser le sujet ce n'est pas parce
qu'un remède à nos questions d'accord
alors v120 question qu'est-ce qu'il ya
est ce qu'il ya à votre avis un rapport
une relation entre le recul de la cgt
dont vous venez de parler et le recul du
parti communiste ces dernières années je
fais pas de même nature s'est pas de
même nature ce sont des problèmes de
nature différente parce que des tués
sont des syndicats hagist d'une autre
manière et dans la vie dans la vie
sociale
faut bien faut bien voir en fait d
assimilation attire aucun syndicat ne
correspond à une formation politique
c'est inexact c'est beaucoup plus
compliqué que ça c'est valable aussi
pour les autres occasions transposer les
clivages politiques sur les clivages
syndicaux c'est une erreur ça correspond
pas à la vérité elle simplement quel est
le parti qui à votre avis actuellement
défend le mieux les travail ça je
garderai bien en tant que représentant
de la cgt d'émettre une opinion pour la
raison que j'ai dit aux questions orales
pour la raison passion pour la raison là
bas non non le syndic et traduit qui n'a
pas de pignoux dans le citoyen krasucki
il a une opinion mais ça je suis pas là
à ce titre donc vous permettrait de
garder cette opinion pour moi mais je
suppose qu on a deux vies mais je
reconnais le droit lui reconnaît le roi
mes camarades et amis d'avoir un choix
différent on vit ensemble comme ça c'est
difficile à comprendre c'est pendant
cette phase il la preuve c'est qu'on y
fait et on l'est on s'entend très bien
mais on se respecte mutuellement
bon on va on va retourner pour finir
cette émission à -cp alors deux
questions des épées jean-louis de seine
oui première de ces questions monsieur
krasucki n'avez vous jamais eu envie de
créer votre propre entreprise
non franchement non mais de contribuer à
créer à faire vis des entreprises
dynamiques b j'ai passé plus de dix ans
de ma vie à empêcher a essayé d'empêcher
que des entreprises ne meurt à faire en
sorte que des entreprises se créent et
pas seulement sous forme de coopérative
ou bien sous forme ou de chose publique
donc quelle vie et et nous avons dû
lutter contre ceux qui voulaient les
démolir
alors oui je suis pour les entreprises
naturellement comment le pays pourrait
t'il vivre sans entreprise ça donne du
travail aux gens et ça fait marcher le
pays
mais moi personnellement m'a jamais pas
venu à l'esprit
une dernière question jean louis la
scène oui à fonctionnaires de rouen
demande combien vous gagnez en tant que
secrétaire général de la cgt par mois et
quels sont vos avantages avantages en
nature j'ai regardé mais ma dernière
fait deux pays
ça me fait n'être 8300 enfin 8400
enfants les avantagerait que je dispose
d'une voiture de fonction
compte tenu que je suis secrétaire
général
société bien que je sache conduirait que
j'aime le faire pour des raisons
évidentes je crois que klein pas ma
personne ni à mes goûts mais la fonction
quelqu'un de cause des voitures et
française c'est une renault s'était
c'était l'heure de vérité de d'henri
krasucki prochaine invitée en novembre
raymond barre bonsoir
[Musique]